local now a case of arson claims the
life of one woman and lands another
behind bars good evening to you thank
you for joining us at five i'm bryan
loftis i'm kirstjen joyce those are the
new developments today from that mobile
home fire on the east side of town we're
told 37-year-old tiffany willis has been
taken into custody joe mohler joining us
live now with the latest details from
the claire county detention center joe
willis is behind bars here today and she
was here while the other woman who was
at the hospital died with burns all over
her body we did go to that neighborhood
and we spoke to a neighbor who lived
right next door he was worried something
like this might happen
tiffany willis appeared in court
thursday afternoon in connection to the
deadly fire at the echo park mobile home
park it started wednesday afternoon mike
wilcox says it was over infidelity he
says people have been living in these
attached units to the mobile home he
tells me he reported the homeless coming
and going but nothing was done the fire
life was burned so you know the heat of
course is going to melt everything and
that's how it started wilcox says he
does not know the woman arrested or the
woman who died he's now forced to move
because his home was damaged my wife was
saying eventually this would happen one
day and look it did it happened last
night
we did contact the county about this
because it is in the county's
jurisdiction they said they didn't have
any reports at that specific unit we
tried to reach out to the company
overseeing this echo park mobile home
park and we've yet to hear back from
them willis is due back in court next
wednesday no bail was set reporting live
in downtown las vegas joe muller live
local now